Caption: two two hey you can hear me fabulous
Caption: um I hope you're all refreshed we have
Caption: James and James here to take us all on a
Caption: pen testing Adventure uh we have one
Caption: James who is from vgw and the other from
Caption: Ben Quest so I'm sure it's going to be
Caption: quite an interesting uh session if we
Caption: have time we'll have some questions at
Caption: the end so feel free to formulate those
Caption: through the session without further Ado
Caption: James and James
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: everyone I'm James number one for the
Caption: purposes of this talk so I work at
Caption: Bankwest in the identity platform
Caption: in 2019 my friend convinced me to join
Caption: his team participating in wactf it's a
Caption: cyber security competition if you're not
Caption: aware of it
Caption: um unfortunately our team kind of
Caption: arrived a bit late to the venue and
Caption: instead of being allowed in the room
Caption: with the other guests we got relegated
Caption: to the foyer out there uh in spite of
Caption: that we took fourth place that year and
Caption: I kind of credit that with uh I guess
Caption: igniting a passion for cyber security
Caption: um so that's me I'll let James two
Caption: introduce himself now yes and I'm James
Caption: number two James number one just
Caption: slightly cooler
Caption: I my interest in cyber security began
Caption: when I was working at Bankwest in the
Caption: grad program I spent six months working
Caption: there in the security operations center
Caption: and the team there was super passionate
Caption: about security and that ended up rubbing
Caption: off on me a little bit from there I
Caption: started participating in things like
Caption: hack the Box wasctf much the same as
Caption: James
Caption: um James and I met together when we were
Caption: working for six months at Bank West
Caption: under peers who's in the room
Caption: uh We've kept in touch ever since and uh
Caption: James suggested the idea of doing a DDD
Caption: talk together
Caption: I pitched the idea of doing a choose
Caption: your own pen test Adventure because it's
Caption: something that I'm interested in and
Caption: that's the idea we ended up sticking
Caption: with
Caption: we also like to do gymnastics together
Caption: on the weekly
Caption: so the goals of the session we've got
Caption: four main goals that we'd like the
Caption: audience to take away from this
Caption: uh as long as you take off at least one
Caption: of those I'll be satisfied
Caption: uh we'd like to give everyone here a
Caption: little bit of a peek at what breaking
Caption: into a website or a service looks like
Caption: certainly when I was working as a
Caption: software engineer I very rarely got to
Caption: see what that looks like I knew that
Caption: managing vulnerabilities was important
Caption: and avoiding flaws that let people break
Caption: in was important but I never actually
Caption: got to see it practically applied
Caption: we'd also like to share with you all
Caption: some practical tips for the engineers in
Caption: the room hopefully whatever service or
Caption: application you're working on at the
Caption: moment won't be vulnerable in the same
Caption: way that our demo website will be
Caption: we'd also like audience participation
Caption: we've formed this as a Choose Your Own
Caption: Adventure we want the audience to feel
Caption: empowered to actually make some of the
Caption: decisions that are going to drive this
Caption: live demo so we're hoping to give you
Caption: enough context that you feel comfortable
Caption: making a bit of a decision and
Caption: participating
Caption: which will hopefully lead to number four
Caption: which is giving you some inspiration if
Caption: anyone in the room is interested
Caption: definitely hit me up afterwards but
Caption: we'll also be sharing some resources at
Caption: the end for anyone who thinks this looks
Caption: cool and wants to do more of it to go
Caption: and do it on in their own time after
Caption: this session so really hoping that some
Caption: of you take that away from this
Caption: so how's the adventure Choose Your Own
Caption: Adventure actually going to work we're
Caption: going to start off by doing a bit of
Caption: giving you a bit of context we'll
Caption: um browse around the website at whatever
Caption: point we're at it's point out some
Caption: interesting things that we've spotted
Caption: and then we'll go into explaining some
Caption: of the options that uh that are
Caption: available to us
Caption: from there you'll see a screen that
Caption: looks much like this one so have your
Caption: phones ready there's a QR code if you're
Caption: at the back it might struggle to scan
Caption: but we'll also read you out the six
Caption: digit number so you can use one or the
Caption: other you either go to straw Paul dot
Caption: live and enter the six digit code or use
Caption: scan the QR code on your phone both will
Caption: take you to a actual straw poll where
Caption: you can cast your votes
Caption: this one's not the real one so this is
Caption: just a demo one I see people doing the
Caption: QR code won't work
Caption: all right I'm gonna hop on the keyboard
Caption: now and James is gonna narrate while I
Caption: start exploring the website
Caption: right so the app that we're going to be
Caption: pen testing is a an online pen store
Caption: um unfortunately because of some VPN
Caption: issues the thumbnails are not loading
Caption: but these are various different pens
Caption: that you can browse through and add to
Caption: your cart there's also a search feature
Caption: up here you can type in a query and
Caption: it'll filter the list to ones that match
Caption: that query there's a gallery here once
Caption: again VPN issues so the content is not
Caption: loading
Caption: um but imagine there's some beautiful
Caption: pen pictures here
Caption: um finally we see a login page so we
Caption: know there's some kind of account system
Caption: on this website we're going to register
Caption: an account for the purposes of this test
Caption: so there's obviously no password policy
Caption: because we're not getting any validation
Caption: errors so we've just put in test as a
Caption: password
Caption: all right I might swap across to the
Caption: video it looks like we're gonna have to
Caption: fall back on a pre-recorded video
Caption: because our VPN is uh acting up
Caption: oh so we've
Caption: we've registered our user we're logging
Caption: in now
Caption: yep so obviously a different user given
Caption: that was pre-recorded so once you're in
Caption: there's a profile page here
Caption: um and in that page you can update some
Caption: of your profile details so your name and
Caption: email address
Caption: and uh looking at the URL we can see
Caption: this is hosted in S3 so that tells us
Caption: that it's a static website so we're
Caption: going to kind of browse through the the
Caption: JavaScript code that's we can see in the
Caption: dev tools and see if we can find
Caption: anything interesting
Caption: so we're going to start noticing that
Caption: it's react
Caption: um and we're just going to try to
Caption: enumerate the routes that are available
Caption: to see if there's any pages that we
Caption: haven't been able to find yet
Caption: um so we'll do that by prettifying the
Caption: code and then we're going to search for
Caption: a route that we know exists in this case
Caption: slash login and we've immediately found
Caption: a list of all of the routes
Caption: so one that we haven't seen yet that's
Caption: interesting is this add product page so
Caption: we're just going to go and navigate into
Caption: that and see if there's anything
Caption: interesting there
Caption: foreign
Caption: error so immediately that tells us we've
Caption: got some kind of role-based Access
Caption: Control in place
Caption: um so next order of business we're going
Caption: to try to enumerate the roles that exist
Caption: um so we're just going to search for
Caption: Strings that tend to appear in role
Caption: names guest user admin and it looks like
Caption: we found a map of rows and it looks like
Caption: admin and user are the only two roles
Caption: that are defined
Caption: since we didn't have access to add
Caption: product page we can deduce that we're
Caption: probably just a normal user but we're
Caption: going to confirm that by looking in
Caption: local storage which is where single page
Caption: apps tend to put their session data and
Caption: uh we can see here that there's a roll
Caption: field and we are indeed a user
Caption: right so having seen that that gives us
Caption: our first goal which is going to be to
Caption: become the website admin so let's look
Caption: at the options that are available to do
Caption: that
Caption: so the first option classic SQL
Caption: injection uh show of hands if you've
Caption: heard of it
Caption: yeah pretty much pretty much everyone
Caption: um so in our case we have this search
Caption: feature which is probably a good
Caption: candidate
Caption: um so if our products are stored in a
Caption: SQL database which is being queried to
Caption: produce the search results we can assume
Caption: that our query might end up embedded in
Caption: a query like this
Caption: where it's filtering on rows that have a
Caption: description field containing our search
Caption: term uh now if the website is vulnerable
Caption: to SQL injection
Caption: um we would imagine that we could put in
Caption: a query that can escape this context and
Caption: do something more malicious with it
Caption: um but there'll be more detail on that
Caption: if we choose that option
Caption: second option
Caption: um is mass assignment
Caption: um so this one relies on the fact that
Caption: we know that there's some kind of admin
Caption: user we know that we can register a
Caption: basic user and the question is can we
Caption: upgrade our existing user or register a
Caption: new one as an admin
Caption: so
Caption: um we can assume that there's some kind
Caption: of role column stored in the user data
Caption: if there's an API endpoint that doesn't
Caption: enforce proper validation it may allow
Caption: us to overwrite some fields that we're
Caption: not supposed to by forcibly providing
Caption: extra input and thereby Force our user
Caption: to become an admin again more detail on
Caption: that if we choose it finally brute
Caption: forcing pretty simple if we spam login
Caption: attempts we might be able to ascertainly
Caption: use the admins username and password we
Caption: don't know their username but we can
Caption: take some guesses at it again we'll look
Caption: at that in more detail if that's what
Caption: gets chosen
Caption: all right so you've seen all the options
Caption: now it's time to vote uh if you're at
Caption: the back and you're having trouble
Caption: reading that the URL is strawpoll.live
Caption: and the pin number is six zero two one
Caption: five six
Caption: so um as soon as we get a clear result
Caption: on the poll we'll uh we'll call it and
Caption: we'll go down that path
Caption: and we won't be waiting for absolutely
Caption: everyone to vote unfortunately as soon
Caption: as we have a clear winner we'll go ahead
Caption: just in the interest of time
Caption: just trying to see if anyone's phones
Caption: are still up we'll go across we'll look
Caption: at the results
Caption: oh
Caption: no internet oh
Caption: minor problems that explains the VPN
Caption: issue
Caption: no wonder I needed to use the the video
Caption: backup
Caption: all right looks like yeah it looks like
Caption: Mass assignment is a is a pretty clear
Caption: winner so uh let's go down that path
Caption: um all right I'll uh well hopefully well
Caption: that's reconnecting
Caption: requires a password on that all right
Caption: I'm just going to go ahead with the
Caption: video
Caption: all right so here we are
Caption: um
Caption: the page that catches our eye as far as
Caption: potential Mass assignment vulnerability
Caption: is the profile page so we can update
Caption: some of the users details so we're just
Caption: going to turn on this tool called burp
Caption: Suite which is going to let us intercept
Caption: requests and actually see what's
Caption: happening behind the scenes when we do
Caption: this
Caption: is going to
Caption: crap so just for a simple explanation of
Caption: how this works normally your browser
Caption: will send web requests directly to the
Caption: backend API we're turning on a tool
Caption: called burps week which kind of proxies
Caption: that takes requests intercepts them
Caption: allows you to tamper with them or repeat
Caption: them and forwards them onto the API so
Caption: that'll just give us some means of kind
Caption: of messing with these requests and
Caption: seeing what we can do
Caption: right so ignore this first request
Caption: because you can see it's just an options
Caption: request just required for cause to work
Caption: this is the one that we're interested in
Caption: this is the one where you can see all of
Caption: the data that we entered into the
Caption: um into the profile form has gone
Caption: through and we're just going to send it
Caption: to repeater which will let us kind of
Caption: duplicate this request later
Caption: and we can see in what comes back here
Caption: that we've got the complete uh set of
Caption: user claims including their role
Caption: but note that all we sent in that
Caption: request was just the details that we
Caption: were allowed to update so now we're
Caption: going to try to tamper with this
Caption: um in particular we're going to add a
Caption: roll field and we're going to put admin
Caption: in there and we're just going to see if
Caption: that succeeds and what happens
Caption: we got a 200 response so uh it succeeded
Caption: in sending the request and we can see
Caption: that the roll field says admin now so
Caption: that's a good indicator that we've
Caption: probably succeeded
Caption: um
Caption: so the next thing we're going to do is
Caption: just log out and back in because this
Caption: website wasn't really designed most
Caption: likely for a user to change their raw
Caption: mid-session so just to avoid any
Caption: inconsistencies
Caption: and make sure we refresh the session
Caption: State all right now that we're here we
Caption: can see immediately that we have a new
Caption: menu that we didn't have before and it
Caption: includes this add product page which we
Caption: can now access
Caption: right so we are now in
Caption: all right so time to reflect a little
Caption: bit on what the developer did right and
Caption: wrong here
Caption: um so what's actually happened is that
Caption: they've intended to uh send these
Caption: um details that are allowed to be
Caption: updated email first name and last name
Caption: and uh superimpose them on the existing
Caption: user record and store that in the
Caption: database
Caption: when we included an extra field roll
Caption: um there was nothing in the API that
Caption: validated that and there was nothing
Caption: that stopped it from being superimposed
Caption: on top of the user record and being
Caption: stored so it just accepted it saved it
Caption: and we became an admin
Caption: all right so what they should have done
Caption: is allow listed user input explicitly so
Caption: you only allow the fields that should be
Caption: updated by that endpoint in this case
Caption: email first name and surname
Caption: um another thing they could have done is
Caption: just to not use local Accounts at all
Caption: it's very difficult to implement good
Caption: user account management there's a lot of
Caption: issues that kind of come into play using
Caption: a third-party service like Azure ad or
Caption: Cognito or auth zero something like that
Caption: will solve a lot of those problems for
Caption: you
Caption: um and also just a note on this a couple
Caption: of popular JavaScript Frameworks are
Caption: vulnerable to this out of the box so
Caption: nest.js and um fastify both will by
Caption: default not validate input fields and
Caption: we'll just kind of deserialize whatever
Caption: you send it and um if you don't check
Caption: for that explicitly they will save it
Caption: all right so now James is going to hop
Caption: on the keyboard I've tethered so
Caption: hopefully we've got internet and if I
Caption: just refresh GitHub yeah okay we've got
Caption: internet we can resume the live demo
Caption: uh I guess just log in on as the admin
Caption: user so now James is going to explore
Caption: what permissions we've got now that
Caption: we're admin and we'll I showed briefly
Caption: uh what was there in the um
Caption: might have to restart the VPN yeah
Caption: do you remember my password
Caption: give that a go
Caption: if not we've still got the video backups
Caption: you might have to refresh this to get
Caption: the the login working again
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh no
Caption: all right we're in his admin as as we
Caption: were before okay we so we've got this
Caption: admin uh menu that we've gained access
Caption: to and there's a number of different
Caption: buttons on there so we've got these
Caption: server logs it the features clearly are
Caption: work in progress with some some sample
Caption: logs in there not quite finished we've
Caption: got some notes that we can access these
Caption: are Developer notes with a bunch of
Caption: to-do list items so the developers
Caption: mentioned that there's an ad product
Caption: feature that shouldn't be using eval for
Caption: parsing some of you might recognize that
Caption: as a interesting thing add drop down to
Caption: the logs page to view different log
Caption: files instead of query parameters that's
Caption: another interesting one for us stop
Caption: using the apis API host as a jump box
Caption: remove unnecessary privileges
Caption: Implement a couple of features so
Caption: there's a bunch of cleanup that the
Caption: developers left themselves clearly a
Caption: working product uh working progress
Caption: website we've got the ad product feature
Caption: which we mentioned earlier that we were
Caption: interested in
Caption: so from this page it seems like you can
Caption: add a new product to the to the page
Caption: to the website
Caption: if we're having trouble it's still
Caption: tethered no okay
Caption: interfering with the with the page yeah
Caption: and we've got add image to Gallery which
Caption: is still under construction
Caption: so that seems to be the extent there's
Caption: no there's nothing else obvious that the
Caption: admin seems to have access to so let's
Caption: discuss some of the options that we see
Caption: ahead of us
Caption: uh yes we're in admin and we've gained
Caption: access to all this but we want to go
Caption: deeper we want to get on to the actual
Caption: host machine
Caption: so how we're going to do that we've got
Caption: a couple of different options
Caption: number one is information disclosure
Caption: this one's relatively self-explanatory
Caption: it means the website discloses
Caption: information that it otherwise shouldn't
Caption: so in this case we're looking at the
Caption: server logs feature and we're going to
Caption: see if we can manipulate that into
Caption: providing us with information that it
Caption: otherwise shouldn't be normally it
Caption: should only give us access to logs
Caption: the developer mentioned that there's
Caption: some work still to be done on this page
Caption: so we'll see if we can manipulate that
Caption: to uncover more information which will
Caption: help us get onto the box next up is
Caption: remote code execution this one's a
Caption: pretty severe one to have on your site
Caption: if it does come up
Caption: uh everyone probably has heard of log
Caption: for Shell uh late last year early this
Caption: year yeah of course quite a panic lots
Caption: of frantic patching that was an example
Caption: of remote code execution there's a
Caption: number of different ways that remote
Caption: code execution can come up but a very
Caption: common theme is deserialization
Caption: in that case an attacker can craft
Caption: especially crafted payload so maybe a
Caption: profile profile picture with some code
Caption: in it that's not really a JPEG they
Caption: provide that to the Target and when the
Caption: target goes to read that data you the
Caption: attacker will has crafted a payload
Caption: that's exploiting the way that it reads
Caption: that data to then get it to do whatever
Caption: it wants
Caption: potentially die
Caption: in this case we'll be looking at the add
Caption: product feature to see if we can
Caption: manipulate it based on the developer
Caption: notes they mentioned they're using eval
Caption: for parsing the the input from the from
Caption: the user so we'll have a look and see if
Caption: we can manipulate that to run whatever
Caption: code we'd like
Caption: so once again we have come to a decision
Caption: Point vote on your phones for whichever
Caption: option
Caption: so for those at the back the code is
Caption: 169648 if you need it
Caption: we'll give it a minute for
Caption: people to have the URL loaded up
Caption: hopefully the results should be off on
Caption: the other side if we're tethered we
Caption: should be able to actually see the
Caption: results ourselves this time
Caption: all right looks like a pretty clear win
Caption: for remote code execution
Caption: thanks for all your votes we'll proceed
Caption: with that option live now
Caption: all right so James is now going to do a
Caption: do a demo of this hopefully we can do it
Caption: live and not use the video recording so
Caption: James is now navigating to the add
Caption: product feature
Caption: and he's turning on Burp again which we
Caption: saw in the previous
Caption: layer
Caption: and James is just going to enter some
Caption: data into this form it doesn't really
Caption: matter
Caption: and he's going to submit
Caption: oh yep turn the VPN back on
Caption: and submit
Caption: and now we can see the request has been
Caption: intercepted by burp again we've got this
Caption: options request which we're not
Caption: interested in we go ahead to the post
Caption: request and James is now sending that to
Caption: repeater for us to
Caption: repeat the request
Caption: so now if James Scrolls down in the
Caption: request we can see the actual payload
Caption: that he submitted in the form
Caption: and what he's going to do now is he's
Caption: going to update that payload to
Caption: something else we're going to try and
Caption: see if we can get remote code execution
Caption: so he's just put in just a string there
Caption: see what we get back out of the API
Caption: we get a 500 internal server error
Caption: unexpected identify okay not
Caption: particularly helpful to us now James is
Caption: going to do a random shot in the dark
Caption: see have a look if uh oh you're missing
Caption: the one yep uh we're just going to see
Caption: if one equals equals one if we get any
Caption: sort of uh
Caption: parsing of that input and returning as
Caption: true so we go to 200 okay from the API
Caption: and okay maybe the error codes could use
Caption: some work it says parsed input could not
Caption: be read correctly with the additional
Caption: information being true
Caption: that us hints that we've got some sort
Caption: of remote code execution because the one
Caption: equals equals one
Caption: has has been evaluated as true
Caption: instead of maybe just being interpreted
Caption: as a string
Caption: so now what James is going to do is try
Caption: and identify what we're working with
Caption: here if you if you Google eval the top
Caption: two results are JavaScript and python so
Caption: James is just going to try a quick
Caption: JavaScript command here and see if we
Caption: get a response back
Caption: so we get a 200 okay and we now have
Caption: what appears to be the current working
Caption: directory of the running process
Caption: hopefully everyone can see that but it
Caption: says basically we see what looks like a
Caption: folder path there
Caption: so now that we've identified that we're
Caption: working with JavaScript and we've got
Caption: remote code execution the rest is
Caption: relatively simple you can go by A
Caption: playbook so what James is doing now is
Caption: installing a tool called netcat This is
Caption: a tool that we'll be using to set up a
Caption: remote shell we're using the Yum package
Caption: manager here assuming that we're working
Caption: with an ec2 instance because the front
Caption: end was S3 it's a relatively safe
Caption: assumption that the back end is ec2
Caption: which allows us to use yum
Caption: uh in this case we've we're using a
Caption: child process to run the command so
Caption: we're not actually getting any immediate
Caption: response back so at this stage we're
Caption: working a little bit blind this is a
Caption: very common theme for these sorts of
Caption: things is you will set something up and
Caption: assume that that has worked when you go
Caption: on to your next step and you'll find out
Caption: at the next step if it actually worked
Caption: correctly
Caption: what James is Now setting up is using
Caption: netcat which we just installed to set up
Caption: a buy and shell listening on Port 8181
Caption: we'll explain more about these reverse
Caption: shells and bind shells in a second again
Caption: we don't get any immediate response back
Caption: because this is working through a child
Caption: process we're just going to have to
Caption: assume that it's worked and we're now
Caption: going to try and connect to the Target
Caption: uh you know in a new tab James is now
Caption: going to
Caption: run that and we don't get any immediate
Caption: response but if James runs who am I it
Caption: seems we're root on the target we're in
Caption: the in the folder that we saw earlier
Caption: and we've got access to the files there
Caption: uh so it looks like we're on the actual
Caption: Target James is now just going to
Caption: upgrade our shell to something a little
Caption: bit nicer
Caption: there we go so we're root on
Caption: 10.00.10 and we're in the in the folder
Caption: that you can see there so we're in we're
Caption: in as a on the host machine now
Caption: we can skip straight to remote shells
Caption: yep so what we've set up currently is a
Caption: bind shell in the commands that James
Caption: run he ran he set up netcat and he's
Caption: configured it on the target to listen
Caption: for an incoming connection on Port 8181
Caption: and then the attacker that's uh my
Caption: laptop here connects directly to that IP
Caption: address on that port and now we have a
Caption: connection the inverse of this is a
Caption: reverse shell where you set up the
Caption: attacker to listen so I would set up a
Caption: process on the laptop to listen and then
Caption: get the actual Target to reach back out
Caption: to me this is much more common in
Caption: practice because you it doesn't require
Caption: nearly as much knowledge about the
Caption: target you don't need to know the IP
Caption: address of your target for it to reach
Caption: out to you it just has to have internet
Caption: connectivity
Caption: you don't need to have a port available
Caption: on the target to bind to because you're
Caption: you're only listening on your actual
Caption: attacker either way the end result is
Caption: the same we have a connection between
Caption: the attacker and the Target and we as
Caption: the attacker can tell the target to do
Caption: whatever we want it to do
Caption: now on to eval let's reflect a little
Caption: bit on what the developer was doing here
Caption: we don't have access to the code but we
Caption: can more or less guess that they they
Caption: knew this was wrong because they left
Caption: themselves a note to remove the use of
Caption: eval
Caption: but they also have this hidden behind
Caption: the the admin role they were the admin
Caption: of the website probably and only admins
Caption: could access this feature so why worry
Caption: about locking it down it's not customer
Caption: facing anyway
Caption: um however yes they did know it was
Caption: wrong if you Google eval JavaScript the
Caption: top five results are all various
Caption: warnings about not using eval so don't
Caption: do what this developer did
Caption: yeah never use eval
Caption: you should instead use a Json parsing
Caption: library to pass Json it under the hood
Caption: probably a lot of them do end up using
Caption: eval at some point but they do all sorts
Caption: of validation and make sure that you're
Caption: not giving it anything nasty before just
Caption: running code
Caption: um so that's it for that layer of the
Caption: demo I'm now going to hop back on the
Caption: keyboard and James is going to narrate
Caption: while I explore our Newfound permissions
Caption: yeah right so we're now on the host
Caption: it's an ec2 instance so we're actually
Caption: on AWS infrastructure
Caption: um so the natural next step for us is
Caption: going to be to try to see what um stuff
Caption: we can get to in the AWS account
Caption: um so one natural Target would be
Caption: querying Secrets manager for secrets
Caption: that are available and seeing if we can
Caption: read any so this is a AWS CLI command
Caption: that's going to do exactly that
Caption: um so we can see a list of secrets that
Caption: have been returned so that means we have
Caption: the list Secrets permission doesn't
Caption: guarantee that we have permission to
Caption: read it
Caption: so there's a secret here that clearly
Caption: catches our eye super duper top secret
Caption: so let's see if we can read that
Caption: all right so this is the CLI command
Caption: that we need to use to actually query
Caption: the contents of that secret
Caption: and we get an access denied exception
Caption: um so that is an AWS IM error that tells
Caption: us that we're not authorized to access
Caption: that resource
Caption: so next thing we're going to do is we're
Caption: going to do a little bit of Recon we're
Caption: going to try to figure out what
Caption: permissions we do have and see if
Caption: there's a way we can escalate our
Caption: privileges so our team is just querying
Caption: the metadata endpoint that the ec2
Caption: instance has access to to find out the
Caption: name of the role that it's using
Caption: and then
Caption: attached to an I am role in AWS can be
Caption: one or more policies which are documents
Caption: that Define permissions so now we're
Caption: going to look at the role policies that
Caption: are attached to that role and we can
Caption: only see one
Caption: so now the next thing we're going to do
Caption: is actually query the policy document
Caption: um to that role that policy contains
Caption: and we can see a whole bunch of
Caption: permissions here
Caption: um when we scroll up we can see that we
Caption: do have the secrets manager get secret
Caption: value permission
Caption: um assigned to us but it's scoped to
Caption: these resources that um that have these
Caption: Arn prefixes
Caption: um and our super duper top secret is not
Caption: among that list we do however have a big
Caption: list of permissions here that we do have
Caption: ec2 run instances is one that catches
Caption: our eye as is create policy version and
Caption: if you scroll down a little bit more I
Caption: am pastoral
Caption: um and if we keep scrolling we can see
Caption: as well that
Caption: um the resource section of that
Caption: um is a wild card so we can execute
Caption: these permissions on any resource in the
Caption: account
Caption: right so that gives us our third goal
Caption: which is just our actual trading Secrets
Caption: um so we want to get this super duper
Caption: top secret first role to do that or
Caption: first option to do that is to use the
Caption: past role permission
Caption: um so the purpose of this is that it
Caption: allows one resource to pass a role to
Caption: another so say you're provisioning an
Caption: ec2 instance uh you can give it a roll
Caption: um and then if we were to leverage that
Caption: we could then connect in to that ec2
Caption: instance via SSH and then as we're doing
Caption: currently with the API host we can just
Caption: use the role that it has available
Caption: second option is create policy version
Caption: uh despite the name this is just an
Caption: update policy
Caption: um
Caption: permission so what it allows us to do is
Caption: create a new version of a policy so at
Caption: the moment if we query Secrets manager
Caption: uh we get an access denied error because
Caption: we don't have the permission to access
Caption: it but what we can do based on what
Caption: we've found is we can just update that
Caption: policy to allow us to do it
Caption: and the next time we try to query it we
Caption: should be able to do that
Caption: all right so time to vote once again if
Caption: you're at the back of the room the code
Caption: is
Caption: 939-765 and again we're just going to go
Caption: into we have an authoritative result uh
Caption: not until every single vote it comes in
Caption: foreign
Caption: still up we'll wait till
Caption: all right
Caption: have a look at the results
Caption: oh this one's pretty tight oh boy it's a
Caption: dead heat all right it kind of looks
Caption: like create policy version is winning by
Caption: a hair but we'll
Caption: if anyone's still trying to vote is this
Caption: it any tie Breakers coming in
Caption: all right all right I'll take the
Caption: silences
Caption: oh there's one close-up
Caption: we give it five more seconds
Caption: someone open up incognito on your on
Caption: your browser and do a second vote it
Caption: looks like create policy versions one
Caption: only just that's the closest we've seen
Caption: it all right so create policy version
Caption: has it so uh let's go do that and see if
Caption: we can get that secret
Caption: all right so what we're going to do now
Caption: is create a new version of the policy
Caption: that's attached to our role so first
Caption: thing we're going to do is go back to
Caption: that query that we used before to list
Caption: the policies that are attached to the
Caption: role
Caption: um
Caption: so the name of the policy that we're
Caption: after is simple policy it's the only one
Caption: there and we've got the Arn of it there
Caption: which we're going to need to make a
Caption: command to update it
Caption: right so this is one very big inline
Caption: command that James is going to paste in
Caption: that's going to do the update operation
Caption: but
Caption: um I will talk to it piece by piece
Caption: right so
Caption: first line of the thing there the first
Caption: main argument is that Arn that we just
Caption: looked up which is the uh policy that
Caption: we're going to be updating
Caption: um following that you can see the actual
Caption: policy document we've just pasted it
Caption: there as inline Json
Caption: um the most important parts are this
Caption: statement here that contains the
Caption: um action section that says Secrets
Caption: manager list secret and secrets manager
Caption: get secret value so that's going to
Caption: allow us to get the secret value and
Caption: importantly we've got a wild card for
Caption: the resource section so this policy will
Caption: have
Caption: um permission to read any secret that's
Caption: in the account
Caption: um finally we can see set as default
Caption: that's just another flag we set which
Caption: makes that the default version that's
Caption: going to be used by any role that isn't
Caption: pinned to a specific version of the
Caption: policy
Caption: our Shell's a little wonky which is why
Caption: you can see all the uh all the commands
Caption: are repeated a second time
Caption: right so having run that uh it succeeded
Caption: we didn't get any errors and we now have
Caption: a new version of the policy there
Caption: version three and because it we gave it
Caption: set as default it is now the default
Caption: um
Caption: right so now we're just going to go back
Caption: to the CLI command that we ran before to
Caption: get the secret value and see if it works
Caption: so it did work we didn't get the same
Caption: error and we have in secret string here
Caption: the actual content of the secret
Caption: um now in this case this is just a flag
Caption: but obviously in a real application it
Caption: could be something uh far more
Caption: interesting like database credentials or
Caption: really anything
Caption: um also worth calling out at this point
Caption: that
Caption: um although we just used our powers to
Caption: uh give ourselves access to read any
Caption: secret in the account we do effectively
Caption: have admin access we could have written
Caption: any policy that allowed any or all
Caption: um AWS API actions um and that would
Caption: have been accepted and we would have
Caption: those permissions
Caption: all right
Caption: so how do we get here oh right so
Caption: um let's just reflect a little bit on
Caption: what the developer did right and wrong
Caption: um oh actually first off we're going to
Caption: talk about automation because
Caption: um we just did that by hand and we were
Caption: lucky in that we had permissions in our
Caption: role to list the policies that are
Caption: attached to the role and to query the
Caption: granular permissions that um that policy
Caption: consists of if you don't have that there
Caption: are tools available
Caption: um that can do it for you um examples
Caption: being Weird Al pacu and red Bodo and uh
Caption: what they'll basically do is uh hit the
Caption: AWS API using uh your credentials
Caption: probate and they can distinguish from
Caption: the error messages that they get whether
Caption: you actually have that permission or not
Caption: um so if you're working blind those
Caption: tools really help you out
Caption: all right now we're going to reflect on
Caption: what the developer should have done uh
Caption: the main thing is they should have
Caption: applied the principle of least privilege
Caption: uh this being an API host it should have
Caption: had one clear role and only had
Caption: permissions it needed for that so they
Caption: should have segregated the duties that
Caption: ec2 instance shouldn't be speeding up by
Caption: the infrastructure nor should it be
Caption: manipulating I am policies
Caption: um and another recommendation would be
Caption: don't put wild cards in your I am
Caption: policies scope them as granular as you
Caption: can to the actual resources that you do
Caption: need to manipulate
Caption: and that brings us to the end of the
Caption: live demo of the pen test
Caption: so what did we learn
Caption: we learned to sanitize and control user
Caption: inputs wherever they arise
Caption: follow the principle of least privilege
Caption: like James just mentioned applied
Caption: defense in depth this is particularly
Caption: relevant especially to that the second
Caption: and third layer where the developer left
Caption: themselves a bit of a mess some notes
Caption: they said to themselves well this
Caption: thing's a bit buggy it's a bit
Caption: vulnerable but it's not customer facing
Caption: anyway I'm the admin who what could go
Caption: wrong
Caption: you should always be assuming that well
Caption: you shouldn't always assume that your
Caption: defenses will fail but you should aim to
Caption: minimize blast radius whenever someone
Caption: can get into one layer to prevent them
Caption: from being able to exploit that to get
Caption: further access
Caption: ideally if there weren't those bugs in
Caption: that for that second layer the an
Caption: attacker that got in through the the
Caption: first bug which was the mass assignment
Caption: wouldn't be able to then get onto the
Caption: actual API host through further
Caption: exploitation they would just be able to
Caption: read the to-do list and that would be
Caption: about it
Caption: the rest of the learnings depends on the
Caption: path we took so I hope you were paying
Caption: attention during the various Reflections
Caption: uh different paths would would have had
Caption: different key takeaways
Caption: how can you get into this uh like I
Caption: promised we're hoping to expire at least
Caption: some of the audience to participate in
Caption: this sort of thing uh try hack me and
Caption: hack the Box are both really valuable
Caption: resources that I've personally really
Caption: enjoyed I spent about a year working
Caption: with Eric who's in the room on various
Caption: hack the Box exercises they were lots of
Caption: fun really satisfying to break into
Caption: particular shout out to ipsec tutorials
Caption: whenever a box gets retired you can be
Caption: sure that there's a really useful and
Caption: thorough video tutorial on how to break
Caption: into that box we'll go up on YouTube
Caption: immediately after
Caption: pentester lab and Os juice drop are
Caption: other things that I haven't used
Caption: personally but have had recommendations
Caption: for
Caption: there are also some certs you can aim
Caption: for in this space not really for the
Caption: beginners but it's something to maybe
Caption: Aspire for I'm also interested in going
Caption: for these myself oscp and ceh offensive
Caption: security certified professional and
Caption: certified ethical hacker that was a
Caption: mouthful uh interesting certs that I
Caption: think anyone in the space could be
Caption: interested in aiming for eventually and
Caption: then like James and I mentioned wsctfs
Caption: or wsctf or really any ctfs are a great
Caption: environment to get exposed to all sorts
Caption: of things related to pen testing or
Caption: cyber in general and they're a great
Caption: environment like full it's very
Caption: supportive community and just a great
Caption: area to learn about these sorts of
Caption: things other than being left out in the
Caption: foyer when you arrive late
Caption: finally we'd like to give a big thanks
Caption: to all the sponsors of DDD without which
Caption: this talk would not have been possible
Caption: so thank you very much and that's all
Caption: from us
Caption: we've got about five minutes left in
Caption: this session if anyone has a question
Caption: for James down the back
Caption: hi
Caption: um
Caption: yeah so uh let's say you're just a
Caption: graduate postgrad or undergrad cyber
Caption: security student so to further increase
Caption: improve your chances and have no
Caption: internship available or made to you you
Caption: just do some more ctfs and then try and
Caption: get some more certifications and then
Caption: fingers crossed and the company will
Caption: look at you even though you don't have
Caption: any years of experience to employ you as
Caption: a pen testers Etc
Caption: um to be clear neither James nor I uh
Caption: professional pen testers
Caption: um but uh yeah in terms of looking for
Caption: jobs most of most of the pen testers I
Caption: know are actually ones who went in from
Caption: software engineering that's not
Caption: necessarily the only path uh obviously
Caption: now more and more there's more focus on
Caption: on uh cyber security studies and you
Caption: could potentially get into that via
Caption: entry level roles I'm most of the pen
Caption: testers I know are not so entry level
Caption: though I don't know I feel like there's
Caption: probably more analyst roles that would
Caption: be a suitable start would be my my gut
Caption: instinct but I haven't done a huge
Caption: amount of research into actually
Caption: becoming a pen tester so can I also add
Caption: there's a thousand people here today and
Caption: so there's going to be a few people in
Caption: the room there's certainly some of the
Caption: organizations are recruiting so the more
Caption: people you meet today the better your
Caption: chances are of finding that we've got
Caption: another question from anyone
Caption: cool
Caption: uh thanks for the talk today guys
Caption: um so my question is I appreciate that
Caption: both of you guys are in software
Caption: engineering not
Caption: um cyber at the moment but
Caption: um my question is in an Enterprise pen
Caption: test
Caption: um how do you know the scope of which to
Caption: you know basically attack the system
Caption: you're trying to you're trying to test
Caption: to because obviously you could spend
Caption: lots of time and eventually break in but
Caption: you probably have limited resources and
Caption: limited time so
Caption: yeah I mean that's that really ends up
Caption: being an agreement between the pen
Caption: tester and the the testy
Caption: um so yeah that that varies I know
Caption: certainly when I was working at Bankwest
Caption: there's all sorts of
Caption: um meetings with the team beforehand
Caption: where you talk about what the exact
Caption: scope of the work will be and I'm sure
Caption: the same can be applied to basically any
Caption: pen test right you you agree with the
Caption: client what the scope for the pen test
Caption: is how long you're going to spend on it
Caption: um you've probably as a pen test you've
Caption: probably got a Playbook of like a very
Caption: systematic approach to testing all sorts
Caption: of vulnerabilities and you go through
Caption: those and if you find stuff you find
Caption: stuff and you report those back if you
Caption: don't you don't uh and then yeah the
Caption: depth at which you're you're pen testing
Caption: again would be something agreed on
Caption: probably prior to the test unless maybe
Caption: you're doing a pure red teaming exercise
Caption: in which case potentially all bars are
Caption: off but
Caption: unlikely awesome
Caption: um we've probably got time for one more
Caption: question if there's anyone else
Caption: can I ask a question then there is a
Caption: question
Caption: more an observation really but um I've
Caption: been in software development for a while
Caption: and there's almost no code base that
Caption: doesn't have any kind of vulnerability
Caption: or something if you look look and dig
Caption: deep enough so there's always something
Caption: to find no matter where you're looking
Caption: yeah absolutely yeah I would 100 agree
Caption: that's kind of a just a quick comment as
Caption: well as that's obviously another
Caption: argument for applying defense in depth
Caption: and just making sure that if any layer
Caption: of your architecture does get breached
Caption: that you kind of minimize the the risk
Caption: that that poses to other layers
Caption: and I'd assume that's where the um
Caption: bounty hunting and the rewards come from
Caption: for a lot of these organizations that
Caption: have seen so you if you're looking for a
Caption: job in this space then go for a bounty
Caption: hunting Expedition another pen testing
Caption: Adventure can I have another round of
Caption: applause for James one and James two
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: so there's about 10 minutes until the
Caption: next session if you need to change rooms
Caption: please do get in there quickly our next
Caption: session here is on web apis and
Caption: two-factor Authentication